today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video
welcome everybody to what has been
mostly mostly sunny but rainy today
Martha's Vineyard I have so much to talk
about we'll talk a little bit about the
show break on the bonus show when Pat
joins me we're going to talk about
canceled culture later on today I do
have some segments planned about what's
going on with coronavirus cases versus
deaths which I got a bunch of emails
about over the weekend but to start with
we have to talk about this complete
softball propaganda interview that
Donald Trump was given on Fox News which
still managed to go completely and
horribly wrong and as you know one of
the themes of the presidency of Donald
Trump has been self-inflicted damage
because a ton of the stuff that has gone
wrong for Donald Trump has been
self-inflicted it's been because of his
own doing had he not been spouting off
on Twitter for example for months and
months and months the entire Russia
probe would likely have come and gone
with a lot less grief for Donald Trump
than than what ended up being an
extended Fiasco had Donald Trump simply
avoided extraneous belligerent
statements about coronavirus it's going
to go away 15 cases will go to 0 and if
instead he focused on building a testing
program quickly that worked we wouldn't
be in the shape that we're in right now
I could give you more examples but I
think you get this idea of
self-inflicted damage from Donald Trump
Donald Trump went on Sean Hannity's Fox
News program and he was given a complete
softball propaganda interview the crowd
was filled with sycophants who felt bad
for how tough things had been for him
Hannity at this point you know he's a
friend of Donald Trump's he was seen
recently getting onto Donald Trump's
marine one helicopter in advance of
Trump getting on they went somewhere
together they regularly speak so the so
so Hannity interviewing Trump at this
point is very similar to like when Don
Jr interviewed Donald Trump recently
it's the type of stuff you expect in
Korea but the differences Trump is so
incompetent that even his son or his
friend Sean Hannity giving him the most
soft ball of softball interviews still
can't make him look good so let's get
into it Donald Trump is of course
running for re-election I've been saying
for a while now
there's been no coherent case made for
why people should vote for Donald Trump
other than Trump attacking Joe Biden
which he's been doing for a while so
Trump was teed up this easy question hey
what would your second term priorities
be what would you focus on in a second
term easy opportunity and Trump couldn't
name anything take a look at this if you
hear 131 days from now at some point in
the night or early morning we can now
project Donald J Trump has been
reelected the 45th President of the
United States let's talk had it what's
at stake in this election as you compare
and contrast and what is what are your
top priority items for a second term
well one of the things that will be
really great you know the word
experience is still good I always say
talent is more important than experience
I've always said that but the word
experience is a very important word it's
an important meeting I never did this
before I never slept over in Washington
I was in Washington I think 17 times all
of a sudden the president the United
States you know the story of riding down
Pennsylvania Avenue with our first lady
and I say this is great
but I didn't know very many people in
Washington wasn't my thing I was from
Manhattan from New York now I know
everybody and I have great people in the
administration you make some mistakes
like you know an idiot like Bolton all
who want to do is drop bombs on
everybody you don't have to drop bombs
on everybody you have to kill people you
have john bolton in fact released
classified material should he be
prosecuted yeah oh absolutely well he
did release classified actually this is
a so this is the softball of softballs
from Sean Hannity and Donald Trump just
can't answer it experience is important
I never slept over in DC I made a
mistake to hire John Bolton let's put
this on the screen and I won't do this
with all of the clips but
to really understand how ridiculous of a
non-answer this is to the question what
are your priorities let's actually look
at what Donald Trump said quote well one
of the things that will be really great
you know the word experience is still
good I always say that talent is more
important than experience I've always
said that but the word experience is a
very important word it's a very
important meaning I never did this
before I never slept over in Washington
so you get the idea so what would your
priorities be Trump can't name anything
here's Donald Trump asked what does he
think are the greatest accomplishments
of his first term again very easy
question important if you're arguing for
people to vote for you to have a second
term you have to demonstrate or at least
argue that you did something good Trump
is unable to list anything other than an
Obama policy from 2014 called veterans
choice which we'll talk about and the
fact that Mitch McConnell forced in some
judges so here's the person asking the
question you'll see just the complete
gushing supporter of Trump the question
is something I'm calling ultra cringe
let's start there
the audience has some questions for the
president we're gonna start from Linda
hi Linda from Wausau Wisconsin thank you
for being here with us today say a lot
of presidents are windows right windows
you know I bought a lot of Wausau
windows over the years and you know it's
I shouldn't give him a free commercial
but they did a good job it's a great
window
they are Wisconsin I love it up here
Thank You Nora
señor Presidente my Cuban background to
it I have a question for you I
appreciate so much what you have done
for this country and I know it's been
tough what do you think is your greatest
accomplishment in your eyes so a lot of
people think it's the fact that we will
have I think before I'm finished this
term will have close to 300 judges
federal judges a lot of people think
because that's a
that's a number that nobody can even
believe and part of it was that
President Obama was unable to get judges
approved in a large number about 142
judges so I took it off got them
approved and then got a lot of proved
beyond so we'll be close to 300 and two
Supreme Court judges great ones and so I
think a lot of people would say that so
the judge stuff understand it's not
really Trump's doing it's really Mitch
McConnell's I've said before Mitch
McConnell has been one of the most
successful Republican operators of the
last many many years McConnell blocked
Barack Obama getting a Supreme Court
nominee held the seat open long enough
that Donald Trump was able to put in
Neel Gorsuch who of course was
recommended by somebody else to Donald
Trump so Trump says judges have been my
biggest accomplishment now it's true
that the people Trump picks are a
disaster but the reason they're getting
in is because of Mitch McConnell the
reason they're getting selected is
because conservative groups are telling
Trump pick from this list it's not even
really a Trump accomplishment but it is
a very good reason to vote for Joe Biden
first of all then here's the second part
of Trump's answer where he says might
one of my biggest accomplishments is
veterans choice which was an Obama
policy from 2014 and we got veterans
choice approved and veterans
accountability that's where you can fire
people that do a bad job you couldn't do
it before very hard to get they tried to
get it for 50 years because the civil
service unions essentially you couldn't
you know get it I got it and the other
thing is veterans choice where if they
can't see a doctor we have great doctors
in the VA but if you can't see a doctor
you go out and you get a private doctor
we pay the bill and it's you have no
idea how great it's been so veteran's
accountability is BS that's a Marco
Rubio bill from 2017 it's trash it's a
trash bill at least it did happen during
Trump's presidency the other policy
Trump mentions here veterans Choice
that's a 2014 Obama policy Trump made
some changes to it but understand that
what Trump is claiming to be his biggest
accomplishments are Mitch McConnell
getting judges confirmed and a 2014
Obama policy it's a comedy of
embarrassment also funny by the way
that is one accomplishment which is
really Obama's is one where the
government gives people healthcare Trump
is right now trying to further damage
Obamacare to take away health care from
20 million people and yet he cites as
one of his greatest accomplishments
Trump says vote for me again because of
Obama's 2014 policy which I tweaked
which gives free healthcare through the
government which most of his supporters
are actually against inconceivable I
mean just just a laughable joke of an
interview then Donald Trump goes into
what I call the Sur routine the Sur
routine is when Trump retells a story of
someone coming to him and saying
something and he always he often says
they came to me and they said sir
XYZ right fill in the blanks in this
case it's they came to me and black
people said sir thank you for calling
out something I guess take a look at
this one it's a doozy we have cities
that are worse in some cases far worse
take a look at Detroit take a look at
what's happening in Oakland take a look
at what's happening in Baltimore and
everyone gets upset when I say it they
say oh is that a racist statement it's
not a racist frankly black people come
up to me say thank you thank you sir for
saying it they want to help these cities
it's like living in hell right so black
people are coming to Trump asking him
please sir get us out of our hell like
cities does anybody believe that black
people who support Trump at 8% are
coming to him and thanking him for
anything and now this gets us to the
climax of this softball interview Trump
again is insisting if we didn't test for
coronavirus we wouldn't have any cases
and he goes into this thing of how there
are 19 different names for coronavirus
take a look thing if we didn't do
testing would have no cases other
countries they don't test minions so up
to almost 30 million tests so when you
do 30 men you're gonna have a kid with
the sniffles and they'll say it's
coronavirus
whatever you want to call it I said the
other night there are so many names to
this I could name 19 names like Corona
19 but I could name 19 names right I
mean listen if we didn't have Border
Patrol we would not find anybody
crossing the border illegally problem
solved right if we didn't ever test for
STDs you'd be totally clean right
no corona virus testing means no cases
got it makes perfect sense repeating
this again and as I've said before he's
had an opportunity to get away from that
horrible answer he could frame this in
some other way but continuing to repeat
that bogus framing and then here is the
day Newmont so this is not the climax of
the interview this is the day Newmont
because it's almost like a sad finale
here is Trump almost sounding resigned
to the idea that he's going to lose in
November to Joe Biden he's talking like
he's already lost listen to this here's
a guy doesn't talk nobody hears and
whatever he does talk he can't put two
sentences together I don't want to be
nice or uh nice okay but I mean the man
can't speak and he's going to be your
president because some people don't love
me maybe and you know all I'm doing is
doing my job don't forget before the
China plague came in and said China
plague before that came in we had the
best job numbers we've ever had we had
the best economy we've ever had Joe
Biden is going to be your president
because some people don't love me maybe
it's all about Trump it's never about
you destroyed trade it's never about you
bungled coronavirus it's never about you
made us the laughing stock of the world
it's some people don't love me so
they're going to vote for Joe Biden
famous last words by the way we can hope
but we've got to get out and vote so
imagine a complete softball propaganda
interview meant to make Trump look good
that's all and Trump couldn't do it in
any way that made sense he misses the
Gimme as we say in golf which Donald
Trump knows very very much about okay
speaking of self-inflicted disasters for
Donald Trump yesterday Donald Trump
shared
a video of a supporter of his yelling
white power at protesters in a Florida
retirement community called The Villages
Trump thanked the great people
supporting him in this video one of whom
is an older white man who yelled white
power as he drove by opponents of Donald
Trump's in a golf cart it's sort of like
the epitome of privilege a white guy in
Florida in a golf cart driving by
protesters standing out in the heat
yelling white power at them and Trump's
exact tweet was thank you to the did can
you believe this is reality thank you to
the great people of the villages the
radical left do nothing Democrats will
fall in the fall corrupt Joe is shot see
you soon here's the video
Trump was reshoring with that comment
and you'll hear just I think it like the
eight or nine second mark you hear this
guy yell white power white power of
course is the calling card phrase of
white supremacists and racists all over
the world that has been for many many
decades so this quickly became another
disaster for Donald Trump he ultimately
had to delete the video from his Twitter
timeline and the White House's
explanation is Trump didn't hear anyone
say white power in the video now when
you look at the video the white power
thing is eight seconds in Trump didn't
see or hear anybody say white power so
this in and of itself is insane and
crazy but there's an entire other part
to this over the weekend news reports
were published in the New York Times
that Russia was reportedly paying people
to kill us and coalition forces soldiers
members of the military in Afghanistan
and offering bounties offering cash
rewards and the White House has
completely fallen all over itself trying
to explain this away saying while Trump
was never briefed
on it well actually the National
Security Council had it but they didn't
go to Trump because it didn't seem
credible or whatever first of all if
that's true if it is true why didn't
Trump get briefed in the sense that even
if these are such serious allegations
that even if they are untrue if it got
to the National Security Council Trump
should have been briefed on it we're
gonna deal with that more later but
there have started to be the claims made
that Trump tweeted a white power video
to distract from the Russian Bounty's
scandal and I have to tell you I don't
buy it
III don't believe Trump's base cares
about the white power video and I don't
believe Trump's base cares about the
Russian Bounty's video I think this is
just Trump being Trump it just happens
that both of these things things happen
at about the same time Trump's base
either doesn't care or doesn't believe
that Trump is even racist it's not going
to help Trump it's not gonna help remove
Trump to point out that he's racist
I don't think that that is really why
Trump would do this and Trump's approval
rating is sliding but it's sliding
because of the coronavirus Fiasco the
economic Fiasco Trump's reaction to
saying let's respond to police brutality
protests by saying send in the military
and use even more force his racist dog
whistles have been around a long time
they didn't hurt him in 2016 I think
that this is just Trump being Trump I
don't believe it's oh my god this
Russian bounty story is terrible
let me tweet a guy saying white power to
make the news talk about that I don't
see it that way let me know if you
disagree I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I
look forward to hearing from you there
and remember that you can get the daily
audio podcast which set new records last
week stunning powerful records you can
get the audio podcast on any platform
you prefer iTunes stitcher I Heart Radio
Spotify Pandora all of them it's
available on all of them we'll be right
back after this the david pakman show at
david pakman
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are esteban sip 20s and Casey Wynn
Esteban and Casey very much appreciate
your support also a big thank you to
Ronald Pearson who's today's longtime
sustaining member of the day Ronald's
been with us hard to believe but almost
five years
grab a membership at join pakman.com the
quick easy simple and inexpensive way to
directly support the david pakman show
and get access to the daily Members Only
bonus show today I will be joined by
producer Pat on the bonus show I will be
talking about what's been going on here
in Martha's Vineyard we will be talking
about Pat's
big vacation how big was it well you'll
have to tune in to today's bonus show to
see you can grab a membership at join
pakman.com ok I've gotten a ton of
requests to talk about canceled culture
so I want to dig into it today and spend
some time talking about this if you
haven't heard of canceled culture cancel
culture is a term that's really all it
is to refer to what is essentially
calling someone out for doing something
objectionable right canceling your
subscription tweeting about it telling
an advertiser not to buy a product
telling a Hollywood not to hire a
certain actor or whatever the case may
be it's a type of activism essentially
and I really want to repeat this because
I think it's important for framing the
entire conversation we should not talk
about canceled culture as the thing that
is new what is new is that it's been
named canceled culture and it's been
dubbed by some a major problem in
society and then we can discuss whether
it really is a major problem in society
or not so my starting point for talking
about cancel culture is first to ask
does this exists is this really a thing
that exists then we ask questions like
is it widespread is it growing for some
particular reason at this point in time
once we figure that out then we can say
well is it a problem is this a bad thing
and then lastly we discuss what if
anything should be done about it right
you we actually want to go through this
in the right way as opposed to doing
what some on the right and maybe a few
people on the left but mostly on the
right are saying cancel culture has
exploded among the woke left suppression
of speech but a little a little okay
we're not going to do it that way we're
actually gonna go through it so is
canceled culture a real thing yes it is
sure it is it is true that sometimes
people will boycott or try to get other
people to boycott or try to get
advertisers to pull ads or get people to
unfollow someone on social media or
whatever the case may be because there
is the belief or claim that a person has
done or said something objectionable
people do things that are perceived as
objectionable all the time different
people interpret it as objectionable or
not and then some people decide to just
go on with their day others decide to
tweet about it others decide to call
advertisers whatever it exists that is
not new
19:33 may be an extreme example the
American Jewish Congress said Germany as
an entity is now anti-semitic boycott
Germany that is something which could be
called cancel culture supposedly a
starting in 1973 various LGBT groups
said Coors Brewing Company has anti-gay
hiring practices do not buy Coors beer a
scary cancel culture right I mean that
we're talking about very similar things
now later we'll get into we don't want
this person speaking at our college
we're gonna get to that okay
but the point is this is not new it's
activism that's been around for a really
long time some people like it some
people don't
their second question is it widespread
and is it more widespread today for
example well that really depends on what
you mean you'll hear people on the right
who claim to be against canceled culture
say you know the hashtag cancel whatever
was used
eleventy billion times or something
right okay well we have social media now
it's bigger than it
three years ago it's bigger than it was
six years ago the fact that a particular
hashtag was used a bunch of times
three months ago doesn't really tell us
in any empirical way whether canceled
culture has reached epidemic proportions
what I do see is people realizing that
money is at the root of much of our
economy and using economic threats to
try to do activism may be useful and
that's where ad boycotts come from and
we can have a debate about whether
that's a useful or effective type of
activism what we have to point out is
that just because something exists and
you give it a name doesn't mean that
it's any more pervasive than it was
before social media may provide a more
convenient means for people to say don't
buy this or don't watch that show or
whatever the case may be but just
because we now have dubbed it canceled
culture doesn't mean it's actually more
of an epidemic so to speak I'll give you
an example that many of you will
remember the regressive left remember
when that term was floating around you
had some people on the left and the
right using this term regressive left
and we did a very we did a deep dive
video about it the left and right used
the term differently the left when they
said regressive left usually meant when
when they when they want to point to
someone who claims to be on the left but
is doing something that's not really
left so for example you might have left
ISM that is really authoritarianism but
it's being hidden as leftism that would
be an example of the left being
regressive rather than progressive now
the right caught on to the term and
started using it to refer to just
anything they don't like about the left
they're like oh that's the regressive
left single-payer health care that's the
regressive left you know performing
policing that's the regressive left so
the reason regressive left is a good
analogy here is illiberal ISM on the
Left existed for a very long time
at some point the term regressive left
was created and the fact that it was
given a nice sounding name made it in
some people's minds seem like it was
more prevalent than it actually was
regressive left ISM has been around for
a long time go to the early 20th century
and you see plenty of regressive left
ISM in a number of authoritarian
countries around the world so you put a
catchy name on it and all of a sudden
you've got articles and interviews and
entire shows devoted to exposing the
regressive left the reality was it
always existed I've always called it out
on the show you put a name on it doesn't
really change it that gets us back to
canceled culture is canceled culture a
problem or has it just been given a name
now that is catchy and so a lot of
people are writing about and talking
about canceled culture let me skip the
name they're using for a moment right
canceled culture implies that there is
some widespread culture of canceling
stuff canceling people boycotting you
know whatever the case may be the
reality is this is called boycott
activism that's what if we unload the
term what we're talking about is boycott
activism this is how capitalism in the
marketplace of ideas works advertisers
can advertise on any show they want to
for any reason they can tell us what the
reasons are or not viewers can choose to
buy a product for any reason or choose
not to buy a product for any reason and
if they want to tell the advertiser why
they're doing it they can if they want
to keep their mouth shut and just vote
with their dollars they can do that as
well
advertisers if they start hearing hey
you're advertising with Tucker Carlson
we're not gonna buy your stuff the
advertiser is free to listen to those
complaints or to ignore them and the
advertiser is free to say we're gonna
buy more ads with Tucker or we're gonna
cancel our ads with Tucker this is not
coercion this is not oppressive you're
gonna hear some people pop up concern
trolling saying you know when you email
a company and say I will not buy your
stuff if you do X or Y that's coercion
because you're holding them economically
hostage and their employees economic
lives guys come on its speech its speech
there's no violence it's a marketplace
this is literally what the free
marketeers claim to want so that's like
98% of boycott activism which some
people call canceled culture it's just
speech its speech you might not like but
it's speech from people expressing how
they believe others should spend dollars
or spend time on social media or go or
not go to a movie based on the actors or
the producers or whatever the case may
be that's 98 percent okay then you get
to the slice of cancel culture or
boycott activism that can be problematic
so there are instances where maybe
somebody said something wrong
offensive discriminatory twenty years
ago and it comes out now and in comes an
angry mob and says fire them cancel them
where I come down on that slice is let's
just be smart instead of stupid let's
use our judgment if someone said
something stupid at some point and it
now came out and they've apologized and
they don't stand by it and it's a
credible apology and we believe based on
their public facing persona that the
thing they said twenty years ago is not
representative of what they believe
today then why would we go and try to
get them canceled so to speak there's no
hard and fast rule here right when
Justin Trudeau was uncovered in
blackface in a facebook a school of
yearbook rather not a facebook a school
yearbook from thirty years ago
he apologized he said it was wrong to do
it that it was immature his modern
platform in Canada as a politician
speaks for itself and it has nothing to
do with somebody who believes blackface
is OK so he did a dumb thing and he took
responsibility why would we go and try
to cancel Justin Trudeau contrast that
with year after year after year of
Tucker Carlson cow towing to xenophobes
throwing out white supremacists red
meets immigrants make the country
dirtier and you know I can't give you
all the examples so there it makes sense
to me oh this is a
sir did this is a distinguishable
pattern I can see why people would want
to target his advertisers and say we
won't do business with you if you do
business with this guy now let me deal
with just one last part of this we've
we've dealt with like ninety-eight
percent and then like another one and a
half we've got like the tiniest sliver
left the anti cancel culture crowd will
often insist people's careers are being
unfairly destroyed at the drop of a
tweet so to speak on a whim because they
said something not politically correct
or not in line with the current
orthodoxy or whatever the issue might be
this just rarely happens I mean that's
the reality Trump is accused of dozens
of sexual assaults he said he grabs them
by the you-know-what he became President
of the United States louis c.k after
having an incident of I believe it was
masturbating in front of someone has a
new project and is doing fine
serial accused domestic assault ER and
musical artist Chris Brown continues to
have a great career
if canceled culture were really so
pervasive and so endemic to the modern
milieu so to speak you would have way
more people whose careers have been
ruined by people tweeting about them or
calling their employer or whatever the
case may be now I know some of you will
say yeah but David what about you know
some someone I've never heard of I don't
deny that in a country of 330 million
people you are going to have examples of
everything when we point out look at all
these guns that are being misused the
gun crowd says well we're not a band
guns or really do much of anything
because of these few isolated incidents
we have the Second Amendment in this
country well likewise just because you
can find someone who was unfairly
damaged by a social media shaming
campaign or whatever I may well be on
your side on individual instances of
this but we have this thing called free
speech boycotts are a part of of liberal
democracies and they have been for a
very long time and there is no
Rasch of every tons of people having
their careers ruined because of some
off-color comment they made decades and
decades ago or even more recently you
can find examples but if this were
actually pervasive the way these people
want us to believe you would have way
more stories of that canceled culture is
a term much like regressive left that is
often used to dismiss people who are
speaking their minds it reminds is the
last thing I'll say on this Trump
derangement syndrome okay
Trump derangement syndrome is a similar
term used in online circles to dismiss
criticisms of Donald Trump as just
that's irrational you have you're
suffering from Trump derangement
syndrome it's a way to dismiss the
actual claims being made in the same way
cancel culture is mostly a term used to
dismiss activism as just a concerted
effort to ruin people's careers for not
being politically correct so let's you
and I together look at specific examples
of bad things let's call them out and
let's move on rather than going down the
same rabbit hole we went down with the
entire regressive left situation I'm
ready to hear from you about this we'll
continue covering it on the show's
Instagram page at david pakman show
follow me on instagram at david
hackman's for the latest on my very safe
socially distance in-state vacation here
in Martha's Vineyard
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show okay I don't
want to spend like a crazy amount of
time on this story today because it's
not that it's not a huge story it is a
huge story but I believe that this story
is ultimately going to do very little in
terms of moving the needle towards the
goal of removing Donald Trump because
his followers have been primed to
dismiss stuff that isn't good for Trump
as fake news but it is an important
story so let's discuss it a little bit
and maybe later in the week we'll have
more more information about it over the
weekend news reports came out that
Russia was offering bounties and Depp
that means it's like a cash bonus right
bounties were being offered by Russia to
Taliban linked militants for killing
American soldiers and coalition forces
in Afghanistan and there's a lot here
historically Russia's political links to
Afghanistan go back a very long time
both Democrats and Republicans in the
United States have had any number of
abortive ventures into dealing with
Afghanistan from a geopolitical
standpoint but the the facts here are
really about what Trump knew if he knew
it and when he knew it and this
allegedly was happening behind the
scenes Russia offering bounties on
killing US and coalition forces in
Afghanistan while Donald Trump was
publicly sucking up to the Russian
President Vladimir Putin and the story
goes that months ago American
intelligence agencies concluded that a
Russian military intelligence unit was
offering secret cash bonuses for killing
these coalition troops
which include American troops and this
made it we know to the National Security
Council by March of this year meaning
we'll talk later about what Trump knew
and when he knew it but at minimum it
made it to the National Security Council
the allegations certainly in other
countries like in the UK they were also
aware at the highest levels of their
government and intelligence services
about these alleged cash bounties for
killing their troops and that leaves us
with two possibilities about Donald
Trump possibility one is Trump knew
about this at the time and he was still
sucking up to Putin or Trump didn't know
about this at the time which means
someone has to get fired for keeping the
president in the dark about something so
major but I'll tell you how it's all
being spun and we may or may not really
figure out what's going on so if Trump
was not briefed about this alleged cash
bounty if he didn't know that's a major
problem because we know it was discussed
at the National Security Council level
and we know that our allies were aware
of it so the the the initial question
was does Trump know the White House said
nothing for the first 24 hours after the
story broke no comment no comment no
comment
and then the White House and Trump
seemed to coordinate the response that
Trump had no idea Trump hadn't been told
he just wasn't aware that this was going
on but again Trump always has to go a
little bit further and Trump starts to
imply he wasn't told because it's fake
news which is just absolutely perfect
for his supporters who have been primed
to believe exactly this Donald from
tweeting quote nobody briefed or told me
vice-president pence or chief of staff
mark meadows about the so-called attacks
on our troops in Afghanistan by Russians
as reported through an anonymous source
by the fake news New York Times so
understand that first Trump is
misstating the story the story is about
Russian bounties Russian bounties if
indeed troops are killed it's not
necessarily a story of
about Russian attacks although there
could have been some he again brings up
the anonymous source thing as reason to
think that it's all fake news he goes on
to say everybody is denying it and there
have not been many attacks on us
nobody's been tougher on Russia than the
Trump administration with corrupt Joe
Biden and Obama Russia had a field day
taking over important parts of Ukraine
where's hunter probably just another
phony Times hit job just like their
failed Russia hoax who is their source
so this is like the standard operating
procedure for Trump Trump calls the
attacks so-called he again says it's all
based on an anonymous source can't trust
that attacks Obama and Biden and brings
out the fake news moniker so we don't
actually know the truth if Trump was
briefed and just decided to say he
wasn't well then he's a liar but we
already know that he's a liar so that
wouldn't be new if Trump was briefed but
forgot which we've heard Trump has no
memory to speak of whatsoever that again
raises the cognitive decline and fitness
for the job sorts of questions and then
if Trump really was not briefed which is
the story they are telling us don't
heads need to roll
don't people need to be fired for not
briefing the president about this maybe
not because their new position as I
alluded to is the reports while
discussed by the National Security
Council were so unbelievable so not
credible that it didn't make sense to
brief the president to which I say
that's absolutely BS I mean that's just
absolute PS if it gets to the NSC and
they determine we don't think this is
true you still briefed the President on
it unless again the if you don't briefed
the president because you want plausible
deniability if you want to hide the
president from this so that he can later
deny having knowledge of it that's a
whole other set of problems
remember Benghazi the endless bogus
hearings that uncovered nothing
this actually warrants hearings and
actually warrants putting people under
oath
so we can figure out was Trump told or
was Trump not told
who's lying where is the responsibility
I wouldn't be shocked to hear that
officials under oath would testify you
know we we did tell Donald Trump whether
or not Donald Trump listened because
he's often watching a TV in the
background while he's getting his
presidential daily briefings whether
Trump remembers that's a separate
question they are for now insisting on
Trump didn't know that's a terrible
defense it's the one that you maybe put
out there if the truth is even worse as
is often the case with this
administration hopefully we'll learn
more about this in the coming week there
are new reports that Donald Trump is all
of a sudden significantly worried and
panicked about catching coronavirus
himself and the context is terrible
polling for Donald Trump against Joe
Biden in 2020 political failure after
failure after failure the White House is
putting in place more and more
precautions to try to protect Trump from
the virus we've seen from publicly move
on from the virus it's all about
reopening the economy return to
greatness transition to greatness all of
that stuff but the reports from inside
the White House are that Trump is much
more worried than he has been at any
point about catching the virus himself
now we know Trump is a known germaphobe
he that's been known about him for a
long time he's been doing rallies though
he's been pretending everything's good
everything's fine but now he's
reportedly panicking so what's happening
is Trump is sending out not just
security detail with advanced teams but
also sort of like germ cleanup details
where they are determining okay this is
Trump's bathroom for this event we're
scrubbing and ultra sanitizing the
entire thing publicly they've said oh
everything's so good that at the White
House we're not loading we're no longer
doing temperature checks and regular
testing for everybody at the White House
that is true but the people around Trump
are still being temperature tests at
temperature checked and kovat 19 tested
all the time you now have a ton of
Secret Service that are quarantine after
two of them caught the virus
sometimes surrounding that's also
Oklahoma rally
of I guess it was a week plus ago ten
days ago now we know of a senior Trump
economic official who was in the Rose
Garden with Trump last week who now has
the virus their name is not being
released is it Larry Kudlow I don't know
but Peter Navarro it's not really clear
who it is but we know about that what I
don't understand is if Trump is really
convinced that hydroxychloroquine or as
he says it hydroxy chloroquine prevents
coronavirus why not just keep taking it
right like if he ever was really taking
it and it protects him from coronavirus
if he's so worried why not take
hydroxychloroquine it's another example
of how what Trump says publicly is the
opposite of what happens privately
testing isn't that important says Trump
and yet everybody around him is tested
every single day meanwhile he's
regularly golfing now I don't actually
believe that Trump catching coronavirus
would be that bad for him politically
unless it killed him
what I mean by that is his own followers
aren't likely to abandon him because he
catches coronavirus they've not
abandoned him with the testing Fiasco
they've not abandoned him over 15 cases
will soon be zero in April they've not
abandoned him over it's going to wash
through and go away like a miracle by
the end of the month if they've not
abandoned him for that why would they
abandon him because he catches the virus
on the other hand the people who
recognize that Trump has failed on the
virus they should already not be voting
for him and I can't imagine their mind
would be changed by Trump catching the
virus either do you disagree with me let
me let me know last thing in the midst
of all this there are rumors again that
Trump has coronavirus and that that's
why we've seen him tweeting recently but
not actually in public I don't even know
that that's true I mean we saw him
golfing recently would he golf with a
mild case of corona virus I don't know
what I do believe is that if Trump did
get corona virus but it wasn't serious
enough to put him in the hospital I
don't believe the White House would tell
us I believe that the White House would
avoid for as long as is possible
admitting that Trump has the virus again
unless it leads to him being in a
hospital for days
I think if Trump gets a mild case we
don't hear about it at all if they can
get away with it let me know your
thoughts remember I am now book a bull
on cameo at cameo comm slash David
Pakman or just search for my name in the
app the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
okay it's the time of the show where we
have to talk about coronavirus
especially after this completely insane
weekend of new cases that we've had
because the United States has quietly
slowly during early-to-mid and now into
late June we have had a period where we
surpassed the worst days from April in
terms of new cases of coronavirus each
day we hit a single day new case record
of more than 47,000 cases on Friday
followed it up with another 43,000 cases
on Saturday another 40,000 cases on
Sunday so the pandemic is worse than
ever what we believed was the peak
nationally in late April has been blown
out of the water by the new case numbers
of late now as a reminder the right
loves to say we have so many cases
because we're doing so much testing this
isn't really a concern we're doing more
tests so we're finding more cases
everything is fine this is not true and
as you can see if you're looking at the
graph that we're putting up on the
screen right now the percentage of
positive tests is going up that's the
blue line one of the things you look for
to see if more cases are merely because
of more tests is you look at whether the
percent of people that test positive
goes up down or stays even as you do
more testing and at the national level
the positive test rate has gone from
about four percent in early to mid June
to about seven percent now okay
that's a 75% increase in the positive
test rate nationally that is insane
for comparison some of the states that
are doing okay so far Massachusetts
Connecticut others the positive test
rate is sometimes under 1% or between 1
and 2% when you do much more testing you
would want or expect that positive stat
test rate to stay even or go down if you
are managing the pandemic well if as you
do more testing the positive test rate
keeps going up it's very very bad
and that's exactly what's going on in
the United States right now now we're
going to talk about states that are
doing well in states that are doing less
well I'm in Martha's Vineyard in
Massachusetts right now why am I here
well the advice is the safe thing to do
as states reopen is to do in-state trips
that require driving but not flying and
of course to wear a mask and all of that
stuff Martha's Vineyard is one of the
parts of Massachusetts that has been
less hit by the virus and when you walk
around you can tell why other other
quite frankly other than tourists from
other states everybody's wearing a mask
there are outdoor pedestrian areas that
are outdoor mask zones there are
restaurants open for outdoor dining
you've got to have your masks on up
until the moment that you sit
everybody's doing it every employee has
a mask you can tell why the numbers are
what they are on the other hand we've
seen a complete unflattering of the
curve thanks to some of the recent worst
offenders and those are as of right now
Arizona the Carolinas North and South
Florida Arkansas and Alabama Mississippi
and Louisiana Utah Texas Nevada Georgia
Iowa California and Tennessee shockingly
the absolutely useless toxic Republican
governor Greg Abbott admits he would not
have opened bars so quickly knowing what
he knows now now this is like such a
minor concession the way you know the
the the real the reality of Texas is
they should have stopped all reopening
and delayed it by several weeks and
actually taken this more seriously
during the closing just getting any any
admission from him any concession is
important he says well I would have
reopened the bars a little more slowly
in his mind opening the stores and the
restaurants you know it was all fine he
just would have maybe opened bars a
little more slowly but again this is a
vile toxic guy his own lieutenant
general lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
is the one who said I would sacrifice
myself and many grandparents also would
for the economy and for their kids or
whatever so
you and I know that what Greg Abbott is
admitting here is BS the fact that he's
admitting anything though is a sign of
just how bad things are going down in
Texas Houston area I see use in at or
near 100 percent we don't really know
because one hospital hit a hundred
percent ICU capacity then just stopped
reporting numbers altogether so we don't
even know the full story of how bad
things are getting in Texas consider
that a bunch of states decided they had
to close months ago when they had 1/10
the cases that these states have now
understand the insanity of that when
they had 90 percent fewer cases than
they have now they said we've got to
close now with 10 times the cases
they're saying we have to be open it's a
recipe for absolute and total disaster
and indeed we are all going to pay the
price for it certainly living in certain
states puts you at a lower risk for the
virus but the entire country is being
collectively punished for example Europe
indeed will not allow Americans to come
in as they are now just days from
starting to open up to travel from other
countries we are up there with Brazil
and India and Russia and a bunch of
other places that have not handled this
well meanwhile you're seeing anti-mask
Patriot after anti-mask Patriot
appearing on social media loudly
proclaiming they will not wear masks
well that's why things are so bad
especially in certain parts of the
country and just as a reminder Donald
Trump continues to say we have the best
testing and we have the most testing we
are 26th in testing per capita in the
world right now 26th not 1st not v not
10th or 15th
we are 26th right now ok I want to deal
now with something that many of you and
I have been noticing about coronavirus
lately cases have exploded I mean just
insane numbers of cases and it's
specifically in some states and not in
others but the death numbers have not
been high for now that's a good thing
I don't want anybody catching korone
virus I don't want anybody dying from
corona virus but the question is based
on the case numbers we would expect
deaths to be higher in some of these
states especially ones where we're
learning that the IC user maxed out so
what's going on there now as a reminder
I have no political perspective here my
ideology on the virus is health it just
so happens the president we have has
failed miserably on coronavirus but I
want to find the real explanation and I
want to find the truth so here's a few
ideas that have been proposed about why
there have been so many cases but
relatively fewer deaths than we were
seeing a few months ago okay one
possibility that's been proposed is that
we are getting better at treating
coronavirus in other words if you get
sick enough to go into the hospital
doctors are now better at treating
because we have three months of
experience and thus you would expect the
death rate to be lower in fact there is
a study called decreased in hospital
mortality in patients with kovat 19
pneumonia and it says that in a lot of
countries fewer people are going to the
hospital and dying and it's a
combination of some hospitals being less
overrun with a better understanding of
how patients should be treated reminder
that's why we lock down when you lock
down you keep the hospitals less full so
the sick people get better care and you
allow time for doctors to learn to
properly treat the disease so hopefully
by the time you get it or your loved one
gets it the medical system is better
equipped to treat very good that's one
possibility
second possibility for why there are a
ton of cases and not as many deaths is
that we just haven't seen the deaths yet
okay the idea in general is it's like 22
days from test to death you get a
positive test it's often five days
before you end up in the hospital it's
often 17 days from hospitalization to
death so it's like a 22 day delay
between cases and deaths the current
spike started I call it June 16th if
this is the explanation that we've just
haven't seen the
yet we would expect deaths to spike
around June 7th or 8th I hope it doesn't
happen if it is that that's what's going
on the death numbers are going to get
very very ugly very very soon third
possibility for why we have so many
cases and relatively few deaths is that
older folks are better protecting
themselves and staying home and it's the
younger people that are testing positive
younger people much more likely not to
need hospitalization much less likely to
die that would be a possibility we don't
have the full data on that that's really
an empirical question we just don't have
the full data on that so we would have
to see I know that there are some cities
that are saying we are seeing more young
people get it fewer older folks get it
we need to see that at the state level
at the federal level lastly there are
some doctors arguing that the virus is
mutating to be less serious that at this
point the virus has weakened and thus
those who are infected are getting a
less serious version of it than what was
going around in March April and early
May I don't want to say too much about
that because we don't know that to be
the case it's a hypothesis it presumably
could be tested empirically that's not
been done most doctors are saying there
is not actually evidence of that right
now and so I don't want to risk giving
people the wrong idea with something
that has not been demonstrated to be
true still a lot to learn but those are
four of the possibilities for why so far
we are seeing unconscionable spikes in
the number of cases but not yet not yet
seeing and hopefully we won't see
corresponding numbers of deaths let me
know what you think about this we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p here's a question about
an interesting scenario that could
present itself if Donald Trump loses in
November take a listen hey David
question as far as likability on this
one but what are the chances that if
Trump loses in this election it's Joe
Biden we have four years by them for
years whoever else is
a chance do you think that Donald Trump
tries to run it yeah I'm just a hard no
on this I I believe that if Donald Trump
loses in November that's it in politics
for him Donald Trump will be what he'd
be 78 78 79 when he would assume a
presidential term in January of 2025 I
just don't don't see it and Trump said
if he loses he's gonna go and work on
something else so I don't believe we're
going to see that whatsoever
I think you're not going to see Trump go
peacefully if he loses in November but
we've already talked about that but I
Trump Donald Trump 2024 I don't see what
one of his kids may try to do then
that's that remains an open question on
the bonus show today we will talk about
our respective little vacations that we
had last week we are going to talk about
the house passing a bill for Washington
DC statehood very very interesting and
and much to discuss we will also talk
about Sasha Baron Cohen crashing a right
wing event and it has led to so much
chaos once again all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member or a patron membership
is join pakman.com patreon is
patreon.com slash david patten show i'll
see you then
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video